les 14 premiers jours du mois de
septembre mais avec chaque jour qui
passe la notion du temps s'évapore la
tente ici est un terminal surtout pour
eux des enfants ils n'ont plus aucun
repère que des clôtures partout qui
limitent leurs déplacements mais ils ont
tous vu et connu pire
à dia et ses parents étaient en visite
en afghanistan pour le mariage de son
oncle quand les talibans ont
soudainement repris la capitale elle
nous raconte son périple vers l'aéroport
de kaboul la semaine dernière avec ses
proches
à 8 ans c'est elle qui sert d'interprète
pour les membres de sa famille qui
l'entourent que les américains ont
évacuées et prises en charge attitude
aurait fui
l'ambiance est elle moins trois points
tout comme akira
elle plaide à qui veut bien l'entendre
il faut absolument aller chercher tous
ceux qui sont restés là bas ces images
et témoignages que nous avons pu filmer
ne sont qu'un petit échantillon de
l'angoissé qui habite toute la base
militaire de ramstein en allemagne 1
point et de transfert crucial qui s'y
transformer du jour au lendemain en cas
de forte
la commandante aiguilles et nouer un
lien n'a jamais rien vu de tel en 35 ans
de carrière milite
22000 évacué en moins de dix jours déjà
qui arrive souvent sans papiers exténué
humala l'enfant qu'on voit circuler avec
leurs familles taille et ils ont reçu le
feu vert pour quitter la base puis vont
monter à bord d'avions et s'envoler pour
les dix-huit le problème de marque pour
chaque avion qui décolle comme un autre
qui atterrit avec ses centaines d'autres
référents
beaucoup dorment dans des tentes souvent
à même le sol car il manque denis et
même de nourriture
ça fait presque une semaine que notre
équipe commune etc avec corys thani qui
attendent désespérément que canada
viennent le chercher lui et 14 membres
de sa famille immédiate
il n'est pas loin à quelques centaines
de mètres de nous mais impossible de
visiter la section où ils sont logés sur
la base militaire il était un interprète
pour l'armée canadienne mais c'est celle
des états unis qui les auraient ska p
avec cette garantie sur papier qu'ils
sont considérés citoyens canadiens
sans nouvelles ni aide consulaire du
canada ils se demandent s'ils n'ont pas
été oubliés dans ce cauchemar logistique
la plus grande évacuation aérienne de
l'histoire américaine ou et ottawa titre
le canada a promis d'accueillir des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés afghans
dont 5000 d'urgence pour désengorger les
bases américaines comme celle où ça mais
pas un seul avion canadien n'a encore
été ulissi sur le tarn
[Musique]
c'est le destin de milliers d'afghans
qui est en jeu devant l'inconnu c'est
souvent l'espoir qui prend le dessus ils
sont en vie même si beaucoup ignore où
et quand ils pourront la rebâtir is it
amaral des restos radio-canada à
ramstein